president trump vowing to keep up his
legal battle over the election and
reportedly has some big plans if things
don't work out
in his first interview since november
3rd the president saying
the doj and the fbi must investigate
allegations of voter fraud
it's inconceivable you would think
if you're in the fbi or department of
justice
this is this is the biggest thing you
could be looking at
where are they i've not seen anything i
mean i've just they just keep
moving along and they go on to the next
president
and president trump continuing to go
after big tech and the media accusing
them of controlling the narrative
around the election it's massively
the powerful it's massively corrupt
the media and big tech section 230
should be taken out
because that's their protection that was
given artificially to them
but it's uh it's a massive form of
corruption and silence and suppression
and president trump apparently has his
eye on 2024. he reportedly floated the
idea of stealing some of joe biden's
thunder
by announcing his next campaign during
inauguration week
greg you called it yes we're first oh
okay
thank you first to market well i
remember juan snickering at me when i
said that was gonna happen you snickered
you want me to do it again yes because i
think it's pretty ridiculous idea but it
just
but it's good if he wants it to happen
it'll happen
the most powerful uh form of bias is
is controlling the faucet right that's
what we're talking about here
so when you take something like the
collusion hoax you turn that faucet up
it's just like the faucet in the tub and
you just leave and it went on for four
years
then you when there's stories you don't
like you can if you're in charge you can
turn that faucet off that could be
either with hunter biden it could be
with the uh uh the election fraud
because there is stuff to report there
that they don't want to report
you can go all the way back as far as
benghazi and you can find out that what
what
cause anchors and reporters to snicker
will not get reported on they will
immediately dismiss it for
there was there were networks that were
doing the same thing they would they
would report on the collusion hoax
and then they would have polls on it so
it was a perpetual motion machine it was
like that drinking bird at the barber
shop
it just fed itself but the the the
election
fraud story is different because it's
not being propelled by the media
and it's not even being propelled by
trump because i i have
a feeling that if it wasn't the movement
if it wasn't the millions of voters that
are pissed off
trump would accept this it's not about
him the media's got this totally wrong
he's just happens to be in front of the
parade
it's the people that are pushing this
because they believe and according to
the polls the rasmussen poll
there is a belief that this was a
fraudulent election it's like average of
40 percent it was 75
republican 30 democrat believe this was
fraudulent right
so this isn't driven by the media this
is an ins this is a feeling
in the public he just he's actually
operating on the will of the people
he's not pushing this all right juan you
want to jump in
well i think he's the you know he's the
guy that what do you call that music man
the guy who's up and from the parade
with the baton
and so then you say oh but look at the
polls that's the self-feeding loop greg
to me this is like the last act of the
trump show and it's getting
old and tired very fast to me
he continues to push this and i think
there's no evidence
uh there's no evidence certainly in
court that's been presented
and if you he's taxed the fbi and guess
what the fbi is his fbi he attacks the
justice department
i think it's really hard to go after
bill barr he's been such a faithful
supporter of president trump but the
president continues to do this today you
know we had wisconsin
recount done guess what joe biden got
more votes
as a result of the recount pennsylvania
has certified
arizona has certified this is over folks
not really
at this point at this point you know
what it looks like to me
is it looks like a con job to raise
money
for trump and his you know whatever he
wants to do in the future
it has nothing to do with the reality of
what you should be telling people which
is let's move on let's organize for the
next election maybe 2024 as you were
suggesting
i'm not sure he's going to be there but
i mean at least you would say oh there's
some reality to that
but there's this would carry more weight
juan if you said this
during the russian collusion business
which went up for four years
look i think that there's clear evidence
that russia in fact interferes there's
clear evidence that there's fraud
no there is no actually more if there
was clear evidence the collusion you
know what i would say to you if there's
clear evidence put it in court i know
that the intelligence agencies in this
country did it one last point on this
i think this is this is curious to me
that it's hurting
republicans in georgia that ronan
mcdaniel the head of the rnc was down in
georgia this weekend
and people are saying to her why what
does it matter if we vote it's all
ridiculous it's all a conspiracy it's
all a fraud that's trump
hurting the republican brand he is going
to go uh
uh rally those voters though on saturday
jesse but
i'm sure you want to talk more about the
election stuff i don't even need to talk
about the
hundreds of sworn affidavits the
eyewitness to the fraud i don't need to
talk about the big tech
censorship the suppression polls the
media bites don't even need to talk
about it what i want to talk about is
this
if this was a clean election then joe
biden
ran the greatest campaign in
presidential history
because he shattered decades of
records over a century of records and
trends in this election
and the media is not even curious about
it i mean how do you have a down ballot
wave on one hand
and then the opposite wave on the top of
the ticket
that hasn't happened for a hundred and
twenty years
you're saying the guy that got more
votes than any other person in
u.s history doesn't have coattails or
donald trump the incumbent actually got
more votes
in his re-election race and ended up
losing
that hasn't happened in 150 years that
joe biden
lost 17 out of the 18 bellwethers that
joe biden won less counties than hillary
200 less counties than barack obama and
still came out ahead
that joe biden lost florida lost ohio
and still won the election
that hasn't happened since 1960 when jfk
some home cooking in chicago or he
underperformed hillary in every major
metropolitan area except philadelphia
milwaukee detroit and atlanta
or the fact that donald trump won more
of a percentage of minority voters for
republicans since
1960 won 95 of republican voters won the
middle class
yet still lost i mean why isn't the
media saying
joe what's your secret how'd you do it
i mean why isn't the media talking about
this transformation of the democratic
party they're not talking about biden
voters
they're not talking about this they're
not crowning
a strategist like a rover an axle rod
they're not even asking joe a question
at all they're only asking trump a
question which is
when he gonna go and that's because
they're not saying that biden won
they're saying trump lost and that
should tell you everything all right
katie last word to you
well the bottom line is that there is a
significant portion of the american
electorate that does not believe this
was fair and square and whether it was
democrat cities or legislatures changing
the rules the last minute
and having a lot of questions about the
way that things were done or
if you listen to some of these hearings
that the trump campaign has been holding
the emergency hearing today in arizona
before the governor
certified the results there before
hearing about these cases if you want to
push aside rudy giuliani and push aside
the trump campaign
lawyers do so and listen to what the
witnesses
are saying about the process whether
it's not having addresses correct
whether they were mixed
matching signatures whether they weren't
allowed to do certain things that they
thought they were capable of doing
weird things that they've been seeing
that they hadn't seen despite being poll
watchers in previous elections
these are questions that should be
answered for the future of elections as
well because we have a whole new system
now
of this mass mail in voting and i don't
think it's actually fair
in the end to just accuse the doj of not
looking into this i mean i know that
there were u.s attorneys in nevada
looking into the 3000 challenging votes
that they had
but the fact is that this is the trump
campaign's burden to
bear when it comes to proving this stuff
and i think they've done a pretty decent
job when it comes to holding these
hearings
and having alternative media sources
outside of the media who've been able to
really
amplify some of these problems that
elected officials on the local level are
actually planning
on changing so it's not going away
that's for sure so
learning to fix these problems and how
to reform them when a whole new system
was put into place
is not too much to ask when people have
serious questions about
what went down all right